[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute tab sieg
aber das ist ein türkisches gericht aus
dem backofen sehr einfach ich habe schon
gesehen in den letzten videos schreibt
ihr unten in die kommentare aber ich
gehen so langsam die ideen aus nicht
denken so york dafür bin ich ja da um
euch ideen zu geben und rezepte nicht
nur jetzt zum fastenbrechen im ramadan
vielleicht gibt es auch natürlich gibt
es auch einige und sich dann zum
mittagessen machen das könnt ihr
natürlich das ganze jahr über machen das
ist ein sehr sehr einfaches gericht
extrem anfänger geeignet und ihr braucht
keine backofen oder sorry gar keine
härter für den backofen brauchte die
schon und ich fange jetzt direkt an ich
nehme zwar diesen mixa da ist schon ein
bisschen älter doch noch nicht den geist
aufgegeben daher benutze ich den noch um
jetzt meine zutaten kleinen haken oder
kleinen nächsten zu lassen aber mir ist
ganz wichtig zu sagen wenn ihr sowas
nicht da hab dann nimmt euch einfach ein
gutes scharfes messer oder hier so ein
wege messer und hakt es einfach von hand
klein das dauert nur ein paar minuten
länger und ist ja auch kein problem die
ganz genaue mengenangaben stehen
übrigens immer unten in der infobox und
ich starte jetzt mit meiner petersilie
gibt das hier in meinem mixa dann habe
ich noch grüne spitz paprika jetzt kommt
gleich alles zum fleisch übrigens und
diese spitz fabrik heißt doch ganz
typisch für die türkische küche es kommt
einfach mit rein knoblauch darf nicht
fehlen und dann kommt noch einiges an
gewürzen dazu also das ist jetzt auch
die türkische spitz fabbrica ein einwand
von sarah weil sie sagt ja auch im
deutschen supermarkt wenn ich jetzt da
wo in der droht eine grüne spitz fabrik
annehme schmeckt ja ganz anders das ist
tatsächlich diese türkische erhält er
dann im türkischen supermarkt er und ich
finde die darf der türkischen gerichten
einfach nicht fehlen
[Musik]
so sieht unsere masse aus den drei
zutaten jetzt aus also richtig schön
sein und jetzt nehmen wir uns das
fleisch ich hab die gewürze noch nicht
dazu gegeben weil ich wollte euch gerne
gleich noch was dazu sagen
und jetzt könnt ihr mit den sauberen
händen das fleisch verkneten ich habe
jetzt eine schnittwunde am finger daher
nehme ich mir heute ein handschuh das
ist ja das ist rindfleisch ist es auch
nicht zu fett weil sonst wird es trocken
also achtet darauf dass es ruhig ein
bisschen fertiger sein und wenn ihr mögt
könnt ihr auch rind und lamm gemischt
nehmen oder irgendwie
60% lahm schmeckt auch sehr sehr lecker
und
jetzt gebe ich das dazu einfach staat
also dazu kneten und bei den gewürzen
ist es so dass sie natürlich salz und
pfeffer verwendet und dann gibt es
verschiedene möglichkeiten das ich gebe
ihr seid schon mal dazu
und pfeffer der bestens vorbereitet
heute
mit dazu und dann kommt natürlich
paprika in ihr hättet jetzt auch eine
rote spitz fabbrica vorab schon dazu
nehmen können eine frische habe ich
jetzt nicht da macht doch überhaupt
nichts sei ganz typisch ist pulver bett
das sind paprika flocken typisch
türkisch die gebe ich jetzt dazu sind
leicht scharf daher bin ich persönlich
da ein bisschen vorsichtiger und dann
paprikapulver edelsüß
kommt auch noch mit dazu und dann gibt
es jetzt zwei varianten entweder nimmt
ihr euch jetzt noch zum beispiel thymian
könnt ihr einfach mit dazu geben oder
wenn ihr sagt ihr habt zufällig meine
sieben gewürzmischung da dann nimmt
gerne die weil es ist nicht typisch dass
gestellt so ist das nicht typisch
türkisch dass eine arabische würze aber
ich mag es einfach total gerne also wenn
es typisch türkisch möchtet dem thymian
und wenn ihr einfach nochmal so
arabischen touristen möchtet die sieben
gewürzmischung weil da sind nämlich auch
den paprika anis fenchel kümmel pfeffer
und zimt und zimt passt perfekt sagt
fleisch habe ich euch ja schon öfter
gesagt es ist damit schon das ist
wirklich sehr sehr gut
[Musik]
die hackfleisch masse habe ich jetzt
ungefähr 23 minuten lange knittel ich
habe auch noch tomatenmark dazu gegeben
ihr könnt auch paprika markt neben je
nachdem was ihr da hab ich mache das
immer wirklich je nachdem was der
kühlschrank hergibt schmeckt beides sehr
sehr lecker und jetzt gebe ich noch ein
bisschen tomatenmark in meiner
auflaufform einfach noch komplett damit
ein rein so wie man es zb bei einer bank
vor mit butter machen würde und dann
kommt die komplette hackfleisch machst
du da rein und wird schön gleichmäßig
angedrückt
[Musik]
so sieht und sagt kebab in der
auflaufform also im taxi jetzt aus und
das gebe ich jetzt kurz an die seite ich
habe gerade ja schon mein gemüse
geschnippelt ich nehme total gerne
kartoffeln dazu ich mag das dann mit dem
wellen schneider zu schnell man habt ihr
einfach nur mal eine schöne optik und
das sind den geschmack einfach durch die
wellen besser auf und dann habe ich noch
tomaten geschnitten ich habe jetzt schon
locken da wenn ihr normale weiße
zwiebeln hat rote zwiebel geht alles das
alles kein problem und später kommt auch
noch spitzt afrika oben drüber dass dies
alles übrigens optional aber ich finde
es gibt auch nochmal geschmack ab und
ist einfach noch mal ein bisschen
leckerer es kommt noch eine art soße da
oben drauf gleich bevor wir das ganze in
den ofen schieben und dafür brauchen wir
nur vier zutaten und fertig nur
tatsächlich also nur wasser dann
tomatenmark oder wie gesagt auch afrika
max könnt ihr euch aussuchen natürlich
salz und gutes olivenöl natürlich auch
wieder werbung vorbereitet so leven öl
noch rein das ganze verrühren und dann
drauf gießen
[Musik]
den ofen hat dich vorgeheizt auf 200
grad ober unterhitze und dann ist das
leckere gerichte offen gewandert für
genau 40 minuten
vielleicht sind es auch nur 35 bei euch
schaut einfach mal ich habe es ins
untere drittel geschoben und es ist so
dass es nach dem backen das ist auch
ganz normal dass ich das vielleicht ein
bisschen zusammen zieht das ist ja auch
viel fett enthalten und daher ist am
äußeren rand falls er kein fleisch mehr
sondern unter den kartoffeln die
kartoffeln sind auch in die mitte
gewandert ich finde es sieht sehr sehr
schick aus ich würde einfach noch ein
bisschen peter sidi oben drüber streuen
und entweder ist dir das so ihr könnt
frisches baguette bruder zu servieren
oder türkischen reis kann ich euch
irgendein rezept gerne unten in der
infobox auch verlinken dazu passt
eigentlich alles oder einfach jetzt so
noch joghurt mit knoblauch und frischen
salat ich glaube so mache ich das heute
abend wir sind ja heute noch am fasten
daher kann ich jetzt nicht im test
machen aber ich werde mir das heute
abend auf und nehme mich da auf
instagram mit ansonsten wünsche ich euch
ganz ganz viel freude beim nachkochen
abonniert main kanal unbedingt damit ihr
solche rezepte auch nicht mehr verpasst
und dann sehen wir uns auch bei meinem
nächsten videos
[Musik]